[Applause]
[Applause]
amazing
the best day of my life
i cried i screamed i celebrated
best way to conclude 2020. i believe the
whole country just took a sigh of relief
well i believe the election was rigged
because we have
the ballot boxes the machines flipping
votes from trump to biden
we want a free and fair election we want
the legal votes counted and the rest
discarded
we're going to let president trump know
that we've got his back
he's taken care of us for four years now
we're going to hold him up
we love trump we love trump
[Applause]
we have a black woman that is going to
be in the white house
yes yes and yes you
ushered in a new day for america
and we made history today starts the day
that i'm able to be seen or communities
able to be seen
it's nice to see somebody that looks
like me
be so high up and it just gives me hope
for my kids
she's kind of like my role model
whenever i walk outside i feel confident
about it
[Music]
it's a little hard to believe that
wisconsin would go blue it's hard to
believe that some states that have been
going red for a very long time all of a
sudden have gone blue you had
139 000 ballots come in at a single
spike
in in michigan you want to find it one
fair and square
then we'll we'll accept that we just
want an investigation our fair election
[Applause]
let this grim here of
demonization in america
begin to end here and now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i think that if we can find a way to
maybe bridge the gap
and start listening to each other it
doesn't have to
end in violence or bloodshed or anger
let us be the nation that we know
we can be a nation united the flag is
the most important part for me and it
makes me tear up a little bit that
uh that's what we're about we're we're
behind this nation
nation strengthened i come from a
divided household so
my partner is voted for trump and you
know i respect him i respect the people
that are for trump but folks we're all
in this together
we have a winner and we just got to do
things together nation heal
today has been amazing because you can
feel the sense of community again
this sense of love everyone coming
together the world needs more love
still we rise together we rise and
together
we make a stronger america
you